>> Stuart: This book is genuinely a set of
think pieces about aspects of the American
dream.
Can you tell a little bit about your own personal
background how that shaped your thought patterns
into this book.
>> Tom: Sure.
I am not a baby boomer.
I'm actually older.
I'm an old guy.
I was born in 1940.
So my first memories of life are about World
War II which seems like ancient history to
all of you.
But it was the greatest single event in the
history of mankind.
I mean, the whole globe was involved.
And freedom as we know it and democracies
were in peril.
I mean, the Germans actually had a plan for
what they were going to do when they got here.
They knew about our munitions factories in
New England and they had plans for agriculture.
It was fought on six of the seven continents;
all the seas at the same time.
50 million people perished before that war
was over.
In a way, it made America.
We were in a deep depression before the war
began.
Everything stopped and was then directed toward
the war effort.
And when the war ended, America became a colossus
on the world stage in terms of its economy.
We're the great manufacturing center of the
world.
Russia had gone hard into communism.
China was one of those places where on the
map it might as well have said 'beyond here
serpents lie'.
[laughter] We just didn't know what was going
on there.
So these veterans came home who had not known
any prosperity.
And they went to college in record numbers
and married in record numbers.
And they built the America that you all have
today.
I was part of that wave as a young man.
My father had dropped out of school at the
age of 10.
My mother couldn't afford to go to college
because it cost 100 dollars a year.
She was 16 at the time.
Very bright woman.
They had these really working class values.
And that's how they raised me.
We moved around a lot from job to job.
And I had,from an early age, a real curiosity
about the world war, about social interaction
in the community.
I was always fascinated by politics.
And got to a small city, by South Dakota standards,
which helped change my life.
I met the woman to whom I am still married
there lot brighter than I am.
And we have had a wonderful adventure.
And we set off not quite knowing what to expect.
But we were pure products of the 1950s when
everything seemed possible for our generation.
And America was changing.
The Civil Rights Movement was underway.
Even though we were engaged in the Cold War
with the Russians.
The field was wide open for people who had
some ambition and some ability.
And in those days if you came out of college
and went to work for IBM.
Steve did at one point.
Probably became a lifer.
The job was going to be there and you could
count on it.
And things had proportion.
The first home my wife and I bought in California
was $42,500 in Los Angeles.
Up in the hills, beautiful home.
And it was in a prosperous little cul-de-sac.
I was making, because I was in television
news and doing pretty well at the time, I
was making $40,000 at the time.
I was buying a home that matched my salary.
So that and gas cost 30 cents a gallon.
[laughter] And California had 20 million people.
Now 35 million people.
So life was kind of good for us.
And then the 60s hit and the boomers -- the
people who came after the war -- began to
push back against what their parents represented.
Because even though I did call it the greatest
generation, I often say it wasn't the perfect
generation.
They came out of the war with a regimented
idea of how things should work.
And the counterculture grew out of the baby
boomers.
They had more freedom.
They were more highly educated.
And they also had economic freedom, because
there was real prosperity in the land and
they could drop out of school and still get
a check from home and do what they did.
That's the kind of short arc of my life.
And then I rose to certain heights in journalism.
Began to write as well as to broadcast.
And began to raise a family: Daughter at Stanford,
daughter at Berkeley, daughter at Duke.
The Stanford daughter now is a physician at
San Francisco.
The Berkeley daughter is a senior executive
at Warner Music and the Duke daughter is a
psychotherapist who has a new book called
Fortytude, about women in their 40s.
So we led this kind of quintessential American
life.
But in our family and certainly in my profession
I never stop taking the temperature of our
society and where we fit in and what was changing.
And I was, always had this great curiosity.
And the business that you're now in, I was
aware of very early and made a point of getting
to know some of the pioneers, Bill Gates particularly
when Microsoft came online and helped bring
him to NBC because I knew it would be transformative
not just in the software but in the content
of it and how we share that information.
And I wrote a book called the Greatest Generation
about World War II and that was in 1998.
And it was kind of a wake up call to the baby
boomers.
They didn't realize what their parents had
gone through.
Through the depression and then during the
war and how they sacrificed to make life possible
for their children.
That started a national dialogue across the
country about values and how we invest in
citizens.
Then we kind of lost our way at the end of
the 20th century it seems to me.
When 9/11 happened, some of you were very
young at that time or I guess all of you were
alive but you were very young.
But it had a electrifying effect on the country.
It just united the country briefly.
In which we began to pay attention to where
we stood in the world and the fact that we
had enemies came as a surprise to us even
though we'd been attacked in embassies and
on our warships in the Persian Gulf.
And we let that slide away.
And so, for the last four or five years especially,
it seems to me that we've kind of lost our
way in terms of where we want to get to and
how we get there as a society as a political
culture as an economy and how we fit into
the world.
In 1980 when Ronald Reagan took the country
through a deliberate recession to try to correct
for inflation, when we emerged from that it
was still a pretty much clear playing field
for America.
We didn't have China, India, Brazil and Russia
as economic competitors.
Oil was around 15 dollars a barrel.
And as you well know, the cost of energy falls
through everything.
In the last four or five years it seems to
me that we've been knocked off our bearings.
So I'll wrap up this little narrative with
a question that I hear because I go across
the country more than any other one from parents
my age and younger.
"Will our children have better lives than
us?"
Because that's always been the essence of
the American dream.
My children will have a better life than I
do.
I've been trying to recalibrate that question.
It's meant mostly in the past will they make
more money?
Will they have a larger house?
Will they have more cars, more freedom to
travel because of their financial security?
And so, we ought to change that equation from
quantitative to qualitative.
Will the next generation give us a more just
society?
More economic opportunity?
Will we begin to educate all parts of America
so that they can have their place in the American
dream?
That led to this book.
And so, in the course of the book, I talk
about proportion when it comes to housing,
about the importance of all of us getting
involved in education, about the place of
journalism.
I'm a grandparent now so I have a sense of
urgency about what I'm leaving my grandchildren,
the life that they'll have.
And the question that I keep coming back to,
and then providing an answer for it, is the
role of all of us.
100 years from now historians will look back
on this time and they won't make a judgment
just about Herman Cain and his current problems
or president Obama or Bill O'Reilly on Fox
News or Rachel Maddow, what the latest Google
app is or dispute with Android they're going
to make a judgment about all of us.
What did we leave behind?
How did we respond to this challenge in our
nation?
The 20th century was called the American century.
And I think it led us to a certain amount
of hubris.
We thought it would always be that way.
Conditions have changed.
So what I'm trying to do is just start a dialogue.
Kick start a conversation, if you will.
And all of you should be front and center
in that because you are inventing the new
world.
>> Stuart: Both in the Greatest Generation
and in this book, you have as one of the themes
that the early experience of the depression
and then wartime -- pain and heroism.
It was what sort of led in a very real way
to the positive aspects of the 50s and 60s.
>> Tom: I'll just tell you one thing that
some of you probably will appreciate.
When I told my daughter I was writing a book,
in effect, what I hope would be kind
broadly, speaking metaphorically, a letter
to my grandchildren, she said, "I don't want
some sappy letter [laughter] about your school
days when you had to wade through the snow
to get to school.
You didn't have as much as we do.
I don't want that."
I said that's not what it's going to be about,
Ashley.
[laughter] And the Greatest Generation which
I wrote about, which I often say, these are
in some cases your great grandparents.
I do think they were formed first by the Great
Depression.
When they were your age there were no opportunities
remotely like what you have.
It was about shared sacrifice and shared jobs
and shared housing and shared food because
it's hard to imagine how desperate times were.
It was just a little passage in this book
that--, about a man who kept a very careful
diary in Youngstown, Ohio, which was a great
steel mill center at the time.
By Christmas in 1934, the steel mills were
operating at 12% capacity.
And that was the heart of American industrial
empire.
People were trying to sell their passbooks
from banks for 70 cents on the dollar.
Hunger marchers were walking down the streets
not like Occupy Wall Street.
They were on their way to Washington, singing
the Battle Hymn of the Republic because they
were in danger of starving to death.
So they came out of all that and then they
were thrown into the war.
And, when they got thrown into military regimentation,
in uniform and then at home, it accelerated
their maturity because they learned to work
together.
They developed discipline.
They knew about risk management at the time.
Back here, they were inventing everything
on the fly.
I talked to a machinist at Boeing who worked
-- he was a farm boy--, but he was very handy
with his hands.
They were building the B-29, which was going
to deliver the long range atomic weapons to
Japan to help out the war.
They were building it 24/7 and he said engineers
would leave us drawings on yellow legal pads
the night before and we would lay the parts
overnight by kind of eyeballing.
Think about the invention of that.
And so, that I think helped form who they
were.
And it created the foundation that we're all
the beneficiaries of.
You, in your own way, are creating this whole
new technology.
And you're finding new ways to advance its
use every day.
So you're a part of that.
But what I would hope that your generation
would do would be to look beyond that technology.
The line that I use is -- and I'm fascinated
by it by the way.
I'm not particularly skilled at it, but I'm
on it constantly.
The line that I use is that "you're not going
to get rid of global poverty by hitting delete
or change global warming by hitting backspace.
And no text message will ever replace a whispered
'I love you' or holding hands on a first date.
Because essentially we advance in human kind
by putting our boots on the ground and getting
our hands dirty and spending nights in scary
places and making a commitment that advances
our own passions and our sense of justice.
And we have to do that as individuals and
then find like-minded individuals to form
coalitions to advance that."
>> Stuart: Fascinating.
If I can change topics a little bit -- you
were the only anchor in Berlin, I believe--,
>>Tom: I think; yeah.
>>Stuart: --the night the wall fell at one
of those defining moments?
Curious your thoughts about the multiple outbreaks
of freedom that we've seen.
That, of course, the opening of shackles on
a number of eastern European countries and
then the past year, the quite surprising,
middle eastern, genuine popular revolutions.
Your thoughts on these outbreaks.
>> Tom: You are living in the age of freedom.
I mean, there has never been as much on planet
earth as there is now in terms of free choice.
Not just in the individual lives you have
and the technology that enables you to practice
that.
But the Arab Spring was a very dramatic development
in your lifetime.
That part of the world will never be the same
again.
It was proceeded by obviously the both fall
of the Soviet empire and the redefinition
of communism in China.
People always ask me about the biggest story
I covered.
And I always say 9/11 was the single hardest
day I ever had.
We didn't know what was coming next and what
the consequences would be and it played out
for some time.
But I believe in my professional career, the
more consequential story in the long reach
of history, was the collapse of the Soviet
Union.
The end of the communism in that part of the
world and the liberation of people in the
Balkans and around the Southern Rim of Russia.
And it's still playing out at this point.
We're still trying to find our way.
When I first went to China, it was essentially
a 19th or 18th century country.
In part of Beijing I'd go for a run in the
morning down to the hutong, part of the which
were the communal areas of Beijing.
And people would be cooking and doing their
morning toilette outside, but it's by lamplight
and they would be cooking with charcoal stoves.
And I'd come back with soot coming out of
my ears because the air was so dense.
I stayed in a peace hotel in shanghai in 1975.
The rats were as big as cocker spaniels going
through the hallways.
And think of the transformation since then.
It's very dramatic.
It's been exhilarating for someone of my age
to be witness of that.
>> Stuart: Now at least some of the more recent
stories had very strong Twitter etc. aspects.
Of course the fall of the Berlin wall was
heavily televised.
And, you know, the media really had an impact.
What are your thoughts on the role of both
the communication media and the human media
in these activities.
>> Tom: Well, I get asked that a lot.
And I have a surprising answer for older audiences.
I say there's never been a richer journalistic
environment than the one we live in now because
on your macros or on your PCs, for those of
you who still have one [laughter] Or for any
of you that have that gives you access to
the Internet, you can with, a key stroke,
dial up the financial times from London if
you want.
You can get the latest release from the Saudi
foreign ministry.
You can get the offerings of the think tanks
in Washington.
I'm on the board of the Council of Foreign
Relations.
We got a first rate website that every day
you can dial into it, in effect, and get a
quick brief what's going on that's very important
internationally.
But you can no longer be a couch potato.
My generation grew up with the idea you go
to the front porch, get the paper, read it
in the morning, see a little bit of the Today
Show, come home at night watch the evening
news; that's it.
Those were your choices.
That's no longer the case as you well know.
But you have to be proactive in where you
get that information.
And develop your own test for whether it's
reliable and credible and useful to you.
I have a friend in Montana who's a very apolitical
woman and she goes on the Internet a lot and
she'll come to me wide-eyed and say, "You're
not going to believe what I read on the Internet
this morning."
And I said, "You're right.
I'm not going to believe it."
[laughter] So I do think that we have to develop
a new kind of vigilance, if you will.
Bill Clinton says that we've got an atomized
society.
That's a pretty appropriate way of putting
it.
We probably s ought to have some sites that
are fact checking sites and places we can
go to make sure that that's true or not true.
>> Stuart: Have you any thoughts, following
upon that if I may, this tension between integration/disintegration
of groups -- not everybody got to watch you
every night with a reasonably authoritative
news story.
But as you said you won't believe this one.
Or more to the point, you will believe it
but you're not talking to anybody else.
>> Tom: It's a fraction of the landscape.
I'll give you the short, short history of
especially television news at the network
level.
That was, in some ways, domestically as transformative
as what you're doing.
When Huntley, Brinkley, and Walter Cronkite
began their broadcast across the country for
the first time if you lived in the remote
reaches of the Cascades Mountains in Washington
or in the piney woods of Georgia, you were
seeing the same thing at the same time and
you could make decisions about the direction
of your country or what was going on in Washington
and be aware of the culture that was growing
up in different parts of America.
Now, of course, that screen is much wider.
It's got many more -- many, many, more -- parts
to it.
And there should always be a role for what
we do in the evening news.
Brian Williams and Diane Sawyer and now Scott
Pelley.
They still deliver to lots of viewers every
night.
Lots of eyeballs.
Here's a question some of you don't think
about a lot because you're going to a different
media but I do this with older audiences.
Bill O'Reilly is a hugely popular figure in
the cable universe and he never tires of telling
you how popular he is by the way.
[laughter] And he often says I've got the
No. 1 show.
And people think he has this enormous audience.
He has half the audience of the last rated
show on the evening news -- Scott Pelley.
And when Katie was there, the audience had
really gone down.
She still had twice the audience Bill O'Reilly
does.
Every night those broadcasts deliver 23 million
viewers.
Divided by 3, Brian is gratefully still in
the lead.
That's still a lot of people looking for reliable
sources of information.
The culture of journalism should always be
important to us in our lives.
It will come to us in different ways now.
We must remember that the press is the oxygen
for a free society.
People need access to information that is
fairly gathered and tells them about what's
going on in their name around them so they
can make decisions about their own life.
Now, I'm going to just let you in on one other
small conversation I had over the weekend
with my friend Walter Isaacson.
I worry that this book would become road kill
on the Steve Jobs expressway, by the way,
[laughter] because of the enormous and appropriate,
understandable popularity of that book.
And Walter and I were talking.
--we were both on Meet the Press on Sunday--.
and he said something that I hadn't thought
enough about.
We're both old traditional book people.
We like printed pages and we like covers that
are first editions.
And he said, "I'm making a real point of buying
as many first editions as I can, because 20
years from now I don't think it's going to
be as easy for me to call up again the electronic
books and to know where they are and to keep
that library in the same way."
And he said, "there's still a magic about
the printed page."
I guess I feel that way as well.
>> Stuart: I'll ask one or two more questions,
if I may.
People should be thinking about questions
they'd like to ask.
We have two mics set up.
In both the Greatest Generation books and
this one there's a very interesting emphasis
-- partly reflective of your background growing
up in middle of the country, small America
-- and then these various explosions.
It's fascinating comments about your own now
extended family which has people from -- everything
from east coast, Russian Jewish family to
Cherokee background and so forth.
It's sort of a fascinating counterpoint.
To what extent do you think that the shaping
of America is being affected by the shifts
of the center of gravity of people and of
backgrounds like that.
>> Tom: Well, you know, America is always
a petri dish.
There's always something going on within it.
That's what makes it such a fascinating place.
We have always been and we always be an immigrant
nation.
Outside of our native American population,
the rest of us all came from somewhere else.
And there's kind of a social Darwinism about
that.
They came here because they had ambition and
they wanted opportunity.
And they wanted to, you know, advance their
-- not just their families, but their dreams
and their ambitions as well.
And you know, we are seeing a different mix
now in our population.
There's a lot of paranoia in the southwest
about illegal immigration coming across the
border.
Some of it is justified because of the violence
that has been visited on those parts of the
world and the influence of the drug cartels.
I often say, however, that there's less concern
for example about Asian Americans moving into
the neighborhood.
In part because they come here with a well-defined
idea of what they want to do -- for the most
part, I can't make absolute generalizations,
but that's mostly the case.
When I was a young reporter in Berkeley, in
the 1960s, in the free speech movement with
Mario Salvio and the place was filled all
day every day with protests against the war,
protests for free speech.
I go to Berkeley now and most of the faces
are Asian Americans and they're engineering
students.
You know they have a whole different kind
of destination in mind for them.
And that's how this country works.
We're constantly evolving and changing.
And I hope always trying to become more than
the sum of our parts.
That's I think a simple formula, but I think
it's an important one.
With my grandchildren, I want to -- my eldest
granddaughter is now a freshman in high school.
But when she was in the 7 grade I went to
her school with other people about my age
and the teacher did a smart thing.
She said, "write down -- the grandparents
and the 7th graders -- what were the best
memories that you have the most -- I suppose
-- striking memories you have of your 7th
grade experience and we'll ask the 7th graders
here to do that.
We all talked about the fact we were segregated
racially.
There was only one who grew up in the Bronx
who went to school where they had people of
color.
The rest of us all went to all white schools.
And of course, they began the 7th graders
with computers and the place they play in
their lives and the fact they had access to
them.
We were the radio generation.
[chuckles] That's how antiquated we were.
I thought it was a very useful exercise to
see how the country has changed.
>> Stuart: One final question, if I may, before
asking other people to line up if you would.
The basic structure of this book is a series
of chapters on various topics.
Each chapter basically begins with a quote
or vignette, then a section about quote "the
past".
They're neatly labeled.
Then the "present" and then the "promise".
I'm very curious what you think is the real
promise -- what you think we should be doing
to get there.
>> Tom: Well, the promise of this country
-- and our rule of law, and foundation in
law and in opportunity and the migrant experience
that we have and the pluralism of America
to say nothing of the extraordinary resources
we have both natural and man-made.
I live all across America from the west to
the east and back and forth and it still takes
my breath away when I fly over this country.
And I believe that the 100 best high institutions
of higher learning in the world here.
People come here because they can be educated
here.
Companies like Google.
I mean, which didn't exist that long ago and
it's now defining this new world.
So that's the promise.
The promise then requires the rest of us to
work even harder at fulfilling that promise
and keeping it alive and keeping it elevated.
Yeah, some of it is hard.
There's no question about that.
But when the historians look back on our time
I would like to think they would say America
lived up to its promise and it's not just
a matter of trying to be "We're number 1;
we're number 1".
It's how you provide a quality of life for
your citizens.
That's what the ultimate promise is.
There are great challenges out there, but
it seems to me that we're up to it.
I'll just tell you one other thing about Bush,
when he talked about the past president -- the
promise.
When I began to write this book, there were
two things that prompted it.
One was that I interviewed President Obama
in Dresden in the spring of 2009, the 65th
anniversary of Normandy, the greatest military
invasion of World War II.
And Dresden had been fired bombed to rubble
during World War II and then it spent the
next 40 years behind communist lines.
But here was a city and a country that was
reinventing itself after its shameful past
of the 30s and really doing a pretty amazing
job.
So when I was interviewing president Obama,
our first African-American president an extraordinary
transition in my lifetime, I said casually
to him.
I was in Berlin the night the wall came down.
And he said to me, "Yeah, I know, Tom, I watched.
I was in law school at the time."
"Oh my God, he was in law school at the time."
[laughter] So that was kind of the opening
that I had in mind for the book.
My editors came back to me and said, "you
know?
People buy books based, now, on the really
first two pages of it.
And that's a wonderful opening, but we need
to come out a little faster and a little harder."
In journalism, it's called tightening up the
lead.
And I got it.
I was a journalist.
So I went back and rewrote the opening to
try and engage people.
And the line I came up with which is central
to the book is "what happened to the America
I thought I knew?"
And it's been pretty interesting to me.
That's the one I get repeated back to me by
a lot of people because they read that.
>> Stuart: Thank you very much.
Let me just start going to the -- we appear
to have at least four people on each side.
>> Tom: If you would speak right up.
One of the conditions of people my age in
broadcasting is we all have severe hearing
loss.
We all had those things in our ears all those
years.
>>Stuart: Ouch
>>Tom: And Walter Cronkite in a setting like
this -- wonderful man -- he was asked a couple
questions.
He was having a hard time with them.
He said, "the acoustics" -- and he said, "oh,
it's not the acoustics, I'm deaf as a damn
post."
[laughter] So speak right up.
>> Stuart: And let me ask our colleagues back
there to adjust accordingly please.
>> Male #1: Tom, first of all it's a great
honor for you to be with us here today but
even a greater honor is for me to ask you
a question.
Can you give us a commentary on the Republican
nomination process, who do you think is going
to winning this? [laughter] t Also what's
the general election -- the presidential election
-- going to be like.
>>Tom: I'm going to hand this out free of
charge.
[laughter] I'm going to give you the best
line to keep in mind for the next nine months
-- maybe even longer.
It's been my vote.
And I've been covering American presidential
politics for almost 50 years.
I believe in the if UFO theory.
The unforeseen will occur.
We don't know yet what conditions will exist
when we go into the booth in November of next
year.
We don't know who the candidates are going
to be at this point, what the tickets are
going to be.
A perfect demonstration of how quickly things
can change is this past week with Herman Cain
and charges of sexual harassment.
The hardest thing in the world to do -- I
honestly believe -- in terms of having personal
courage that doesn't require you to face enemy
combatants, is to run for president of the
United States.
Friend of mine who was a senior political
advisor so Jack Kennedy said if you want to
run for president of the United States you
have to be prepared to strip naked every day
at high noon and take a bath in the most popular
public square in town.
[laughter] Every day during the campaign.
Because that's how you're examined.
I would hope that we would break out in terms
of the dialogue and conversation that we've
been having.
Most of these Republican debates thus far
have been either kind of persnickety attacks
on one another or only about job creation.
And that's the central question.
But they have made what effectively are kind
of grandiose promises without any backing
them up.
There hasn't been enough examination of that
so far.
I was struck a week ago by the fact that Rick
Perry was going hard after Mitt Romney because
he may have hired, unwittingly or otherwise,
an illegal gardener.
And the next day Muammar Gaddafi was shot
as we changed the future of Libya.
So the contrast between arguing about illegal
gardeners or getting rid of Gaddafi was fairly
striking to me.
[laughter] And I think we need to worry a
little more about that -- the Gaddafi experience
-- than the illegal gardeners, quite honestly.
>> Female #1: Thank you so much for coming.
I was wondering who your most challenging
interview was.
>> Tom: Pardon me?
>> Female #1: Who your most challenging interview
was.
>> Tom: I get asked that a lot.
I was the first journalist to ever interview
a general secretary of the communist party
in the Soviet Union and it was Mikhail Gorbachev.
It was a signal about how they were changing.
That was tough because we knew that he wanted
to send a message to the west but at the same
time he had to play to the hard liners back
in Moscow.
And it was going to be one hour simultaneously
translated.
It was quite successful.
It got a lot of good reviews and it was the
beginning of a long friendship that I have
with him to this day.
But it was very tough because he had no experience
with a reporter before, certainly with an
American reporter.
When I went in to do the interview, the arrangements
had taken nine months.
Typically, the Russians in those days were
still doing things in a Stone Age way.
They had put their own microphone on him and
it looked like a bad sculptor's idea of a
clenched fist.
It was this piece of iron hanging off his
jacket.
So I just signaled to our audio technician,
"we need to change that."
And I reached over and I took his microphone
off.
And as I was taking it off.
"My God, I'm just reaching over without telling
him I'm taking the general secretary of the
communist party who has an entire nuclear
arsenal without saying."
He's staring at me.
And I said, "I'm sorry Mr. Secretary, but
this is what I have to do on my job every
day."
Through the translator.
And it came back through the translation and
he said, "you would not believe what I have
to do on my job every day."
[laughter] And that was a challenging interview.
But I would say this.
When you interview heads of state, they're
pretty practiced and it's tough to get them
to get spontaneous with you.
Margaret Thatcher was always an enormous challenge.
She would just eat us for breakfast.
The reporters would sit there and she would
just swat us aside.
She was very self-confident about what she
was doing.
Bill Clinton could talk about anything.
You just light him up and he'd take off in
about nine different directions.
[laughter] So that was always fun, but it
was also challenging.
But the fact is in the long many years I've
been doing this, the most impressive people
I've interviewed are people whose names I
didn't know because they were people doing
courageous things not expecting any attention
or credit for it.
It really began in the Civil Rights Movement
in the south.
I'll never forget a night in America's Georgia.
The town was a tinderbox.
It was ready to go up.
The African-American community had gathered
in their end of town to decide whether to
march.
And the white red neck population, including
the Klansmen had said anybody who marches
tonight will be dead by morning.
That was just advertised up and down Main
Street.
Streets were lined with pickup trucks with
broad axes and with shotguns and pistols.
And when the small Baptist church where the
small African-American leadership had gathered
broke up the meeting about midnight this beautiful
young woman maybe 19 came out wide-eyed.
And I said, "what have you decided?"
And she said, "well, we're going to march."
And I said, "My God are you terrified?"
I was scared.
And she said, "Of course I am."
I said, "why are you going to march?"
She said, "We have no other choice."
And marched.
And that has lingered with me forever because
it showed the strength of her conviction.
And the Civil Rights Movement changed our
country so much for the better that it's almost
hard for me to tell a young audience what
it was like then and how much better off we
are now.
Dr. King liberated not just black America.
He liberated all of us.
Even the most tolerant of us, he liberated
through law and non-violence.
And he did it without a cell phone.
[laughter] He didn't have tweet.
He didn't have texting.
He didn't have e-mail.
He was able to do it through the power of
his conscious, the strength of his voice,
and his trust in the rule of law in this country.
It was pretty amazing.
>> Female #2: The anecdote actually feeds
nicely to my question.
You've seen social and political movements
rise and and be successful and I'm sure you've
seen some wither away and just die.
What are your hopes and predictions about
the Occupy Wall Street movement?
>> Tom: Well, I watched a lot of social protests
from the ground up in years and this one has
as little definition as any one I've ever
seen.
[laughter] I understand the rage.
I don't know what the goals are at this point.
And because it's kind of amorphous.
And it has gotten the country's attention.
What I have said to -- I have a number of
friends on Wall Street.
And some of them are even responsible.
And I've said to them, "if you don't begin
to change from within, there are going to
be more restrictions placed on you and people
will have less to do with you."
It's always going to be an important part
of our economy.
That's how we finance things.
Google couldn't exist without people providing
money for Google to get started.
Now Google can buy the world, of course, [laughter]
but in those days it was different.
And there are people doing good work every
day on Wall Street.
They need to get together and send a message,
"you can't have the government bailing out
Wall Street to the tune that it did and then
having everyone at the end of the first quarter
paying themselves these enormous bonuses and
not expecting some kind of a pushback.
But I think Occupy Wall Street has to look
within itself and say, "what is it we're trying
to achieve here?"
There's a wide range of opinions everything
from nihilism all the way across to labor
practices.
And as a result I don't think they're having
the impact that they might otherwise.
That's what I think.
>> Stuart: Please.
>>Male #2: Umm [clears throat]-- do you see
a relationship between the growing inequality
and distribution of wealth -- the concentration
of wealth in the hands of the few and the
decline of the communism and the decline of
the laborer -- the power of labor.
>> Tom: Yeah, I do.
The 99 versus 1 percent I think is a very
smart way of positing that.
I happen to be in the 1 percent and I'm grateful
for that.
I won the lottery in my business in some way,
but it doesn't mean that I'm unmindful of
what's going on in the other 99 percent because
I have members in my family who are in that.
And where I grew up, that's where a lot of
people are.
Again, the whole CEO compensation disparity
between those at the top and those on the
factory floor needs to be addressed I think.
I believe very, very much in a meritocracy
incentive and providing that incentive for
people to do well.
I know that there are business leaders that
have a very marketable skill and they can
go to the marketplace and get rewarded for
that.
But we've kind of just lost control.
The middle class is losing ground.
It's not even stalled.
It's losing ground.
As you go across the country, you find so
many 2-parent families where both parents
are working just to keep up.
And then when the housing bubble burst, they
may have lost their home or it certainly declined
in value for them.
Those are the seeds of what I call "domestic
insecurity" -- the strong economy provides
domestic security in this country.
Well being.
A sense that anything is possible.
It's very hard for people to think of doing
other big jobs like reforming education or
changing anything including politics if you
don't provide them with opportunity for economic
security.
I just don't think it's been addressed very
much.
Perfect example.
Almost none of the political dialogue that
we have going on at the moment really specifically
offers any kind of solution to the mortgage
meltdown in America.
We have 20 million homes in America that are
either in foreclosure or are stress state
or in peril of going into a stress state.
And I have yet to see an imaginative idea
for relieving that some.
A lot of people in those homes want to pay
something.
You know, they're determined to hang onto
their home.
It's their entire net worth in many instances.
And they're not getting very much help on
that.
It's that kind of boldness that we need to
hear more of and less about illegal gardeners
in my judgment.
>> Stuart: Matt.
>> Matt: Well, the first thing you said was.
>>Stuart: Louder.
>> Matt: The first thing you said was how
World War II was a tremendously important
event.
And you, yourself, were to a certain degree
at the forefront of a lot of lionizing that
went on about 10 years ago, cultural touch
stones like Saving Private Ryan that sort
of thing.
Do you feel there's some danger in that we
see now in the era of fourth generation warfare
where no war going on really properly resembles
World War II that we have a tendency to paint
things as being World War II.
That there's -- at least in our political
discourse-- there's this idea that if there's
ever a question about going to war people
who say no are Neville Chamberlain.
There's a Hitler, a final boss of this country,
that if he's killed then freedom will prevail.
And World War II looms so large in our imagination
that it colors how we react now even in places
where it doesn't fit.
>> Tom: That's a very important question.
When political leaders decide to go to war.
They did in Iraq.
It kind of triggers a form of nationalism
which everyone wants to be in the parade to
see the boys and girls go off to war.
Except people who've gone to war.
They all have different feelings about those
who've seen combat first hand.
Especially the military leaders.
But the military leaders are there to carry
out orders and to offer their best advice.
When we went to war in Iraq, I had some real
doubts about the long-term possibility for
it.
I'd been over there a lot.
I was inclined to believe he had weapons of
mass destruction.
I wasn't for sure.
But I'd been with the UN inspectors they were
led around on merry chases.
He was a bad guy.
I could see that.
Around every corner, when you were in Baghdad
or in the outlying areas, about how people
lived in utter fear.
But my long-term concern was that it was going
to be harder than anybody in the administration
was saying that it would be.
That it would be more expensive in terms of
blood and treasure.
And that at the end, Iraq would revert to
kind of tribal governance.
That it would be the Shiite versus the the
Sunnis; the north versus the south.
And I knew the country was so broken that
despite these promises of the administration
that they could finance a lot of the war by
getting oil revenue -- 70 billion dollars
out of it.
They haven't been there.
The intel on the ground was terrible.
So you're quite right.
We don't learn the lesson from war to war.
Vietnam, you would have thought you said you
can't have a war and have guns and butter
at the same time.
Just have one piece of it.
I write in here about Robert McNamara about
how at the end of his life he went around
and had a kind of a natural confessional about
how we went to war on the wrong terms.
But the emotion of war often takes over.
Honestly it's harder to stop a war than it
is to start one.
And that's the terrible commentary on where
we are.
>> Matt: Thank you.
>> Male #3: Thank you so much for coming.
It's nice to have someone speak who's near
to my age than the average age here.
[laughter] I was -- I confess I'm a pioneer
boomer.
I was born in 1948.
And I further confess from my personal history
that I was a pioneer nerd as well.
Sir, there's a great deal in your description
that I don't recognize particularly about
the 1950's upbringing.
In our household World War II and the depression
particularly the threat of persecution hung
over us like a paw.
I also don't recognize a lot you said about
opportunities to be educated.
I'm fortunate my greatest achievement in this
life is that I raised a son who is now gainfully
employed in a job with benefits.
The reason is we taught him to write and we
taught him to negotiate.
We live in a suburban district, wealthy school
district, high achievement scores that gave
a totally inadequate education and threw me
off the school board because I wanted to change
that.
Where in your description do I hear about
this?
I think this is the biggest threat to our
country -- the lack of skills in the general
population -- what can we do?
We are unwilling as a people to do it.
How can we change it.
>> Tom: Well I actually talk a lot about that
in this book.
The one encouraging part about public education
that I have seen recently is that people are
beginning to talk about it.
If I were to give you a quick synopsis it
would be very much what I presume is your
thinking.
Those of us who could move to the suburbs
or send our children to private schools and
we left the inner city to its own devices.
And it was kind of one size fits all and we
walked away from our moral obligations to
these schools in the inner city and in the
great urban areas of America.
That is beginning to change.
People are now beginning to pay attention
to it.
New York is certainly imperfect process at
the moment.
Joel Klein and Mike Bloomberg said we are
not going to allow this to go on the way it
has.
There are lots of private enterprises that
are trying to help out.
I'll just tell you about two in the book that
will be of interest to you.
There is a very successful commercial real
estate developer in Atlanta by the name Tom
Cousins.
I really didn't know him for a long time but
I'd always hear the same thing.
He's a great man people would say.
But I'd be skeptical about that.
So I set out to find out about him.
He's a third or fourth generation Georgian.
He developed a new form for commercial real
estate development.
Made a lot of money.
But he was always troubled by what was going
on in the inner city and in the African-American
neighborhoods.
So he read about a place called East Lake
in Georgia.
Right outside of Atlanta, southern perimeter
of Atlanta.
And it was called Little Vietnam because it
was a war zone because of drugs and school
dropouts.
Five percent of the kids graduated from high
school in that area.
It had in the middle of it a historic golf
course called East Lake.
It's where Bobby Jones, the legendary golfer,
played his first round and last round of golf.
Tom is a golf aficionado.
He went down and he had a hard time selling
to his community.
He said, "I want to start by restoring that
golf course and I can sell big memberships
and we'll take the money and we'll begin to
change the area."
To cut to the chase, he did restore the golf
course.
He took all the money and a lot of his own.
He built mixed income housing.
He brought in black middle class families
and working class families, put them there.
He created a charter school, named it after
a prominent African-American physician by
the name of Charles R. Drew who did a lot
of work in the blood area.
Named the school after him and made him the
hero of the school.
It is now the number 1 school in the state
of Georgia.
They are now called purpose-built communities.
Warren Buffet saw a documentary about him
and said, "Sign me up."
They've done it in Indiana, they're doing
it in Charlotte, they're going to do it in
Omaha.
They did a big project in New Orleans.
There's another school in Cincinnati called
Taft, worst school in the Cincinnati school
system; one of the worst in Ohio.
The Cincinnati school district did a very
bold thing.
They said, "We're going to take down the old
school, in effect.
We're going to leave the physical building.
We're going to make it a magnet school for
technology."
They sent out a very aggressive principal.
He said to the teachers at lunch, "If you
don't want to work harder than you have been
and be part of the most successful school
I don't want to see you after lunch."
Most of them came back.
He went into the city of Atlanta and talked
to a service club and the man who runs Cincinnati
Bell, Jack Cassidy, went to him and said,
"I'm your partner."
And he went out there and put computers in
every classroom.
He wired the neighborhood for wireless.
Gave the kids a cell phone number.
And it's now the number one school in the
state of Ohio.
A lot of that is going on.
We just need to connect the dots all over
the place.
>>Male #3: Yes, there's many--
>>Tom: You're quite right.
I did a documentary one year in Milwaukee
because Springdale is the name of the suburb,
I think.
They got a great school system.
One block away, you have a bombed out Milwaukee
school system.
And the
good folks in the wealthy suburb were providing
some scholarship but never enough.
We need to break down those barriers, And
make it available to everyone.
I think there's going to be a lot more choice.
I think they're going to get more people in
the teaching profession.
And the business that you're in is going to
make it easier for people to have access on
a daily basis if they want to home school
or go home and work on things.
>> Male #3: There's one in Middlesex County
too.
My son went to.
It's brilliant.
We just have to do more of it.
Thank you very much for coming.
>> Tom: Well, one of the things I say in my
book my generation if we want to leave any
kind of a legacy, that is one place to begin.
We are all beneficiaries of good education
for the most part.
My wife has a book club in a school in Harlem.
I've been helping in a school in the south
Bronx, an elementary school, with a wonderfully
innovative public school administrator.
So we've been involved in these kinds of things.
And we all need to find a way to do it.
Thanks very much.
>> Stuart: Try to squeeze in a couple more
people.
But succinct please.
>> Female: #3: Hi.
You mention that the fall of communism in
the Soviet Union is one of the greatest moments
you lived through and that happened in no
small due to America's involvement.
You also touched briefly on the Arab Spring.
What do you see as we go forward and we try
to find our way as a country, what is our
role in the larger global humanity and what
role should we be playing as other countries
are struggling to find their identity as well.
>> Tom: Well, I do think a challenge for your
generation, and you are emblematic what's
possible, is to repair and restore the American
education system.
Because that's going to be the great leveler
in the future of the global economy is how
well-educated we are.
You know, my guess is that most of you have
already traveled physically to different places
and so on.
I've got grandchildren who have -- who are
ages 14, 12, 5 and 3.
All four of them have been to Europe already.
[chuckles] I didn't get there until I was
28.
I was just the only one story that comes out
of the book.
This is the adaptation of my generation to
that generation.
When my San Francisco granddaughters and I
were in Hawaii, at one point we all -- I took
them down to the beach, the girls, when they
were 11 and 9 at the time.
And we were on the beach.
And we've been out kind of body surfing and
we came back in.
And I could see the waitress coming down the
beach at the resort hotel where we were.
And my mind is racing, "how can I order for
the girls?
what am I gonna order for them?"
And before I could say anything, the 11-year-old
said to the waitress, "Ma'am, we'd like two
virgin pia coladas, would you like to join
us Tom?"
[laughter] I don't have to worry about that
anymore.
But I do think education is the place to begin.
And understand the acknowledgment that we're
not colossus America without challenges.
We're still an enormously powerful country
with the greatest cyber technology in the
world that was invented here and the greatest
possibilities.
But we can't take it for granted.
We have to work at it every day.
And so, that's why I used the phrase reenlist
as citizens.
Find something that you care about personally
that will also be greater advantage of this
country.
>> Female #4: Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
I watched my grandfather who was a World War
II vet and my dad connect to Walter Cronkite.
I'm thankful for your time with us because
I started watching you on the Today Show.
So you were my Walter Cronkite.
[giggles] And we looked to journalism through
folks like you and Mr. Cronkite as really
-- yes, being the oxygen for us.
I feel like there's so much pollution now
in journalism.
There's not as much oxygen to breathe.
I feel like much of it is editorialized so
that middle America just gets the opinion
before they actually hear the news and then
discuss it at the dinner table or at McDonalds
or via blog or whatever you do now.
Is there recalibration that needs to happen
with journalism so we keep our government
leaders to task and everything else.
>> Tom: I think you need to work harder at
finding straight reportage because opinion
is the flavor of the moment.
I mean, even in the New York Times in their
weekend review, now has shifted so that it's
a lot of opinion.
But they make it clear.
I don't have trouble with opinion as long
as it's labeled opinion so that you kind of
know, "Well, this is somebody who's going
to tell me what he or she thinks."
And then there are other places you can get
the information.
But again, it just goes back to what I was
saying originally you just have to work harder
at it.
You have to be more proactive as a news consumer.
And you know on these small screens, there's
a world of possibilities in terms of what
you can get.
And that's pretty exciting.
I also think by the way -- we were talking
about education -- the whole business of online
education and what's available out there,
what you can access, is just phenomenal.
I mean, you can stay at home and home school
yourself at my age as it were about what's
going on in or on any interest that you have.
Our family has been going to Turkey for the
last couple of years because it's intersession
between the the east and the west.
It's a beautiful country and it's got great,
not just Byzantine sites, but ancient Roman
sites.
I go online and I get this virtual tour and
read the best archaeologist and find out where
to go.
That wasn't available not so long ago.
>> Stuart: Let me take one last one thank
you.
>>Tom: Last one?
OK
>> Male #4: As the gentleman mentioned there's
a lot of people in this company in their 20s.
Very young company.
I was just wondering if you could talk about
what your conversations have been like of
people of that age right now specifically
your views on the character of our generation
in the 20s right now and how they compare
to other generations at our age.
>> Tom: Well, frankly I'm in awe of your generation.
I mean, you're so smart.
You know, the clich about you teach your
parents to drive this new technology.
But it does not mean there are some things
I think I can kind of alert you to.
I was at Stanford giving the commencement
address a few years ago.
My daughter, the Stanford graduate, I saw
her in San Fransisco, she said you better
read the Stanford Daily, Dad or the Cardinal
as it's called.
So I read it and they had surveyed the graduating
seniors about what they think of me as a commencement
speaker.
[laughter]And one of the young women said,
"Brokaw?
That's like listening to adult radio."
[laughter]So she gave her name unfortunately
and I gave her a shout-out when I got to the
podium.
I'm not going to tell you who it was now.
But I said, "Ba Ba Ba, turn your iPod to adult
radio and listen to whatever pleases you.
I've got something to say to these students."
And what I said to them is what I said earlier
about not all the answers are in your laptops
or your PDAs; you have to figure out.
These are really just tools.
It's your heart and your mind that will use
them most effectively and that's what you
have to decide for yourself.
I was at Stanford recently doing something
else about H 1 B visas about how we can keep
the best and brightest who come here from
around the world.
And a law school student, a senior, I was
working in the law school courtyard before
I went out on my next appointment and this
young man came up to me had I thought a very
appropriate question.
It's one I'll leave in the room for the final
question.
And that is, he said, "Mr. Brokaw, is my generation
going to lose the true meaning of friend?
What does friend mean?
Is it a verb?
Do we have lots of friends just because they
show up on our Facebook?
Do we use it too casually or should we be
thinking more about the definition of friend?"
I think it's a really good question.
Who's a friend and why are they a friend?
And how do you measure a friend beyond friending
someone on Facebook.
>> Stuart: Thank you very much Tom.
[applause]
>> Tom: Thank you.
[Applause].
>> Tom: Let me just end with one Google story
because I've actually been.
like everyone else, I've been fascinated by
your business and your company since the beginning
of it and I've gotten to know it pretty well.
I've been on the campus in California a couple
of times and then I went to the Google zeitgeist
conference in -- when they had the first one
I think in Palo Alto as I remember.
And they asked me -- I guess I can say this.
This is going to get streamed at some point,
right?
[laughter] I got to tell you this story.
It's already been out there.
Eric Schmidt asked me to do something.
He asked me to come and speak.
He said I'm going to have your friend Yvan
Chouinard come as well.
Yvan Chouinard is a man who founded Patagonia
-- that company.
He's one of the great great environmentalists
of our time.
And one of the most inventive people that
anybody ever will know.
He reinvented all the climbing equipment.
But he's a Luddite when it comes to technology.
He just doesn't -- he thinks that man was
given hands as tools and we ought not to lose
the opportunity to use those tools.
and I said, "well, you don't want Yvan to
talk.
He's not very good at speaking.
Why don't I interview him?"
That's a great idea.
So we waited till the morning was over and
they had a lot of highbrow stuff about the
philosophy of the Internet.
John Chambers from Cisco was there talking
about the global routing questions that are
going to be involved.
And so, I went out with Yvan after this.
He's about 5 foot 2, or 3.
He's one of my very closest friends.
And he's had just a phenomenal life.
More first routes in Yosemite And everywhere
in North America than anybody else.
Climbed all over the world.
Built this company from nothing.
And we sat down.
And I said, "I think most of you know who
Yvan Chouinard is."
There was a lot of nodding.
"so we'll begin with basic questions."
Yvan, do you have a cell phone?
He said no.
And I said "do you have Blackberry or a smart
phone"?
"What's a Blackberry?"
[laughter] I held one up and he said, "why
would I have one of those?"
I said "well, you have a company that has
a lot of online business.
You have a lot of stores."
And he said, "yeah, but when I want to talk
to my manager, I go in and see him or I call
him on a regular phone.
But they don't need me pestering him.
I don't need one of those things.
I don't need for people to know where I am
all the time.
I don't want to be a part of that."
Then he went into -- he said to the audience.
We were given these hands as tools.
He said, "I started my business, in effect,
as a teenager fixing old cars.
1938 cars taking apart, building them back
again; rappelling off cliffs to do falconry.
My hands allowed me to do that and I strengthened
my legs and I learned how to climb vertically.
I was in a ice cave for ten days in Monte
Fitz Roy in Chile.
And I had a lot of time to think.
Because I had no other devices to distract
me.
That's where I got the idea for the company
that I now run.
I needed better clothing that would last."
Then I said to him, "but Yvan, in your passion,
climbing, cyber technology has now moved in.
People are now taking their laptops with them
when they go to Himalayas or when they go
to climb somewhere."
You could just see the energy drain out of
him.
And he said, "Yeah, there are probably some
of you in this room who have done this.
You've hired an outfitter for 50,000 dollars
in the Himalayas.
You picked out a peak that you're going to
go climb.
You got your little espresso machine.
You've gotten your laptop.
You've gotten yourself, bought a lot of Patagonia
gear.
We're thankful for that.
You got yourself all dressed up.
And then you fly to the Himalayas and your
guide and outfitter meets you and the sherpas
carry all your stuff up to base camp so you
don't have to carry anything.
And you get there and you get a little satellite
dish and you go online and you say to your
wife and family, "I'm here it's going to be
the greatest adventure of my life."
And the morning you're supposed to summit,
the guide wakes you up fixes your breakfast
and then one ropes up in front of you and
one is behind you to get you up to the summit
and get you back.
And then you come back to base camp and you
write to your friends and family, 'I summited
today.
I have one of the great achievements of my
lifetime'."
He looked out on the audience.
"I don't know how else to tell you this except,
you're an asshole when you left and an asshole
when you got back."
[laughter] It went totally viral on the Internet.
And he got a standing ovation from the room.
So I saw it.
We got to keep that perspective in there as
well.
Thank you all very much.
[Applause]